get your shopping bags ready whether you
are shopping online or in stores macy's
the sponsors of this segment is your one
stop shop for all things holiday i went
down to the fashion show location for a
preview take a look
well with the holiday countdown begin
i'm here inside macy's at fashion show
talking about my favorite thing holiday
shopping and joining me is personal
stylist anthony diaz thank you so much
for having me thank you for coming on in
today stealing of course well happy
holidays we're talking all things gifts
so let's get right to it we have a lot
of options here where are we starting
yes so well obviously macy's is the
number one fragrance destination of the
world so we have gifts not only just for
him but also for her as well so a little
bit of everything and i am seeing
something sparkly catch my eye back here
what do we have here i mean nothing says
i love you than diamonds right i mean we
have such a great selection of pieces
downstairs in our uh jewelry department
i mean everything for everyone yeah it
makes your holidays a little extra
sparkly which i like so let's shift for
the guys because we have some fun things
over here on the table so we have polo
is probably number our number one seller
for for men for the holiday season we
got great looks uh they have their
little infamous insignia with the little
teddy bear in front so cute and speaking
of teddy what is this right here so
obviously we jumped onto the bandwagon
for the teddy uh trend so we have it in
the uh
purse we even have it in the slippers
for uggs and slippers for guests yes
more sparkle i absolutely love it love
slippers okay and if you're wearing your
slippers you want to get cozy at home so
we have tons of great cozy pieces for
the home
starting with our brand new uh in-house
brand
and nothing says holiday than holiday
betty okay there's so many fun things on
the table here but if people need a
little help you guys offer gift guides
right goodness if you're needing a
little bit more inspiration you can go
to macy's dot com forward slash gift
finder a little bit of something for
everyone for your mom your dad the
kiddos oh we have kids let's talk about
toys so we actually did a part great
partnership with toys r us so we have
tons of great toys you're going to see
at most of the macy's everywhere oh
that's so fun i see some of the star
wars toys over there i'm sure kids are
loving that this year is going to be the
number one seller and they always see it
they're calling it a hot seller there
and so while the kids are playing with
the toys maybe the parents are in the
kitchen using some of their foodie tools
yes so we have instapot we have a fryer
we have some great cookware available
for everyone a little bit of everything
i just want it all and before we wrap up
here i want to talk about something
really special that macy's does the
believe campaign yes we are partnering
with make a wish foundation for the 14th
year in a row
now one of my favorite things is when
you write a letter to santa
you get a dollar for up to a million
dollars donated to kids with critical
analysis ah so everything goes to make a
wish i love that it's just a fun way for
the kids to write a letter to santa or
the adults can take part too and if you
guys want to check out any of these
holiday gifts you guys can make it
really easy at macy's you can go online
you can use the app or they can just
come right to you and you'll have them
do their holidays
well thank you so much anthony be sure
to come by macy's i know this is where i
will be black friday around christmas
time you name it
thanks so much jillian
well thank you to macy's for sponsoring
this segment the macy's holiday gifting
is happening now through december make
sure to stop by at their location inside
the fashion show mall or you can give
them a call at 702-731-5111